I mean cuz the Nostalgia worn off yet
you know hitting these red carpets and
obviously you've been so amazingly
recognized throughout award season for
bombshell this is a special night for us
we just had a little moment I took a
photo with the producers and we just
really guys yeah it's special what's
your concern sometimes it feels like a
very long road to get a picture like
this mate it does not always feel like
it is I have to ask you I saw the the
funniest story the other night about you
talking about somebody who who tasked
you to make out with your nose I love
about you you you're such a good
storyteller and you have fun during
awards season what's kind of the secret
to surviving is it just laughing through
all these shows anything right yeah oh
my gosh I would be in an early grave it
was just here he choked his personal
life's a disaster but luckily awards
season right exactly
you know I gotta ask you obviously megyn
kelly shared her reaction after seeing
BOMs show and it kind of made you
emotional why was that
this all happened to them you know we
made the movie about it and and I acted
all of that stuff but this actually
happened to all of them and to hear them
reflect on it and talk about it and and
to just hear these continuous stories of
a how pervasive sexual harassment is in
the workplace it's emotional yeah and
the Oscar nominations for the movie for
you I mean what was that like to hear
I'm blown away by all the loves that
we've been getting for the film and I'm
super grateful for all of it because for
those of you who make these kind of
movies you know how hard it is to just
get people to talk about it but this one
seems to get people really wanting to
share and talk about it so that feels
really good does it make you want to
tackle any other real life stories what
is next for you in terms of what you
want to do I'm taking a break you are
are you yeah my children don't know who
I am
and just be a mom for a second we have a
couple of things in post-production
we're so our slate is so full anyway
that it's I'm never not going to work
but I need to just take a moment will
that break include binge watching The
Bachelor I think you have some episodes
to catch up on unless you've been
watching a real time like the rest of us
I'm watching it in real time I am and
how did you know what I'm doing at my
time on I'm so transparent seasons off
to a wild start yeah have any favorites
yeah
yeah there's a lot I don't know their
names yet so champagne girls great
Kelsey sorry Kelsey I'm gonna get there
it's not you I'm just bad with names the
other Hannah is that's gonna be
interesting and I'm and I'm putting
money down that
Hanabi is gonna show up at some again
people think they're saying at proposals
or they're showing up a proposal and
she's throwing a whole spanner in the
wheel yeah I'm good to Theron I mean you
can do the Oscars you can do the
bachelor you can do it all thank you
thank you enjoy the evening yes and
congratulations
[Music]